Bonjour, pour commencer je citerai François Mitterand qui disait
"pour dire oui, il faut pouvoir dire non"
- Perdu!
-Pardon ?
-Oh laissez tomber...
Aujourd'hui, je reçois le champion du monde de ni oui ni non, c'est Michaël.
Bonjour
Alors vous êtes le champion du monde en titre, en fait ?
Je répondrai par l'affirmative.
D'accord... Vous savez qu'on peut se parler normalement là hein?
Etes vous le champion du monde de ni oui ni non, oui ou non ?
La réponse n'est pas négative, bien au contraire.
D'accord, mais... on joue pas en fait là
Vous avez conscience de ça ?
Absolument.
Donc vous voulez bien qu'on se parle comme des personnes normales ?
Il en est fort probable.
Ok! Euh...
Donc je vois que vous êtes marié, c'est ça ?
-Hm hmm.
Et vous avez deux enfants.
Brandon et Spirou.
Vous les aimez?
Brandon, énormément.
Spirou, exactement pareil
Ok donc on va faire une pause.
Non, non, Michaël, je parle d'une pause dans l'interview. Parce que je pense qu'on s'est mal compris en fait.
Là on est hors compétition. Je sais pas si vous avez compris le but de ça.
Moi je suis un être humain qui veut juste parler avec vous.
Faites un effort!
- Ok j'ai compris!
- Vous vous étiez encore dans le...
-J'étais vraiment en mode compétition!
Comme ça les réponses, bam bam bam!
- Ok parce que je me suis dit "on s'en sort pas"!
-J'ai pas tilté!
- Bon on y va! On y va officiellement alors !
Euh donc vous êtes marié.
Effectivement.
- N'oubliez pas, on joue plus!
- Et vous, vous êtes marié?
- Bah euh...
Exact.
-Elle est jolie?
- Ou... Elle est à mon goût.
Et la vôtre ?
- Magnifique. C'est tout ce que vous vouliez savoir ?
- Pas du tout. Avez-vous un animal ?
- Un labrador.
-C'est un chien ça, n'est-il pas ?
- C'est ce qui se dit dans "30 millions d'amis".
Aimez-vous les animaux ?
- Seulement les volatiles.
- C'est un mot pour dire "oiseau" ?
- Sans doute, l'aviez-vous compris?
- Vous avez l'air tendu...
- C'est inexact, je suis concentré c'est différent, et vous ?
- En totale maîtrise verbale.
- Donc on peut continuer l'interview.
- On peut tout à fait continuer l'interview, c'est ...  [sonnerie de téléphone]
Excusez-moi.
- Allô ?
Hmm.
Comment ça ?
Mais quel hôpital?
Ok, j'arrive tout de suite.
- Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
- Je viens de perdre mon grand père...
- Ok on va arrêter l'interview...
Du coup vous pouvez couper.
Euh Michaël, on repousse. Vous allez rejoindre votre famille et vous vous occupez d'eux.
On fait ça ?
- Oui c'est mieux...
- BAM ! Ca y'est il l'a dit, il l'a dit !
- Ah !
Champion du monde de que dalle, mon con !
T'as dit oui ! T'as dit oui !
Le mec donc ça y'est papi est mort, euh je...
Je perds pied !
La semaine prochaine nous recevrons Oui-Oui le personnage préféré des enfants.
- Mais vous êtes horrible...
- Affirmatif !
Ca va ?
- Non...
- Ah ! T'as encore perdu !
Mais tu t'enfonces, tu creuses ! Comme ton grand-père !
T'as perdu deux trucs aujourd'hui toi!
Ton titre, et ton papi !
Oh putain ! Bah tu m'auras fait passer une bonne journée ...
Hahaha qu'il est con celui-là !